let's dig into some questions from the
audience I want to start with a question
from Kyle who said hey guys should news
sites have a system the checks if you
read a story before you can comment or
share now I looked into this finland
there's a finland news site that
actually makes you take a quiz about the
story before you're allowed to comment
on it so some kind of system to try to
figure out whether the person has
actually read the article before leaving
a comment would probably if we talk
about the effect of this it would
probably reduce trolling drastically
maybe I'm not in support of it though it
just seems condescending to me like we
have to test whether you're
knowledgeable enough about this article
to leave a comment on it or share I have
no problem if a site wants to enact a
policy like this hey do it you know
there's a lot of enemies I mean the
point is is it going to stifle the
conversation above and beyond the
decrease in trolling many times we will
send out tweets from the at david pakman
show at d pakman twitter accounts and it
will be a link to a video of ours and of
course the description is 140 characters
like 115 accounting for the space that
the link takes up and it doesn't
encompass everything that's said in the
video and i'll start getting all sorts
of just insane trolling messages that
are reacting to something in a way that
clearly shows the person didn't watch
the video either saying I didn't mention
X when I did mention X in the video or
whatever it would be great to be able to
clean up all of that nonsense by forcing
people to have to watch the video before
they're able to comment on it now
obviously we're talking about how can
you have a Twitter system that will know
if you watched a YouTube video it's all
completely hypothetical and theoretical
but conceptually I think it's a pretty
good idea but I think those people who
respond to the tweet without ever
checking the video yeah I think they
kind of look ridiculous as if they
didn't do their homework and and it's
one of those things that maybe should
just be up to a free marketplace of
ideas yeah I goes in the end they're the
ones that look bad I don't disagree but
especially if someone just sends me a
tweet their followers unless they've
done what's called a dot reply their
followers aren't even going to see that
it
only me who's annoyed pat and therefore
such a system could prevent us from
getting annoyed by people trolling us
yeah i just i don't think it's kind of
weird your again I'm not I'm not for it
I mean yeah if a website wants to do
that I think that's totally fine but
like I said I think it sounds kind of
condescending I know we want to improve
our media literacy here but also people
check out articles in their spare time I
mean for most people it's not their work
it's just you know their interest and
they want to keep up on current events
and then we go to second it so yeah you
may skim it and you don't want to make
it seem like work you want to actually
draw people to read the articles and not
just ignore them because we think it's
another to do for them I think that the
intermediate would be you have to at
least scroll through the entire article
before being able to comment but the
comment box is almost always at the
bottom so you'd be doing that anyway you
know I like you how the ideas out there
I think it's a good thing to you know
come up with ideas to promote media
literacy and to combat trolling but this
just isn't the one I am completely in
favor of this if any individual media
outlet wants to enact it the sort of
logistics of it and the practicality I
think can absolutely be debated but I
think that's interesting and check out
that fin finish website that does this
what if we did this for YouTube so
someone has to watch an entire youtube
video before they're allowed that will
completely eliminate any first or second
comments I think yeah people who just
try to immediately post well not
necessarily it would just happen if it's
a three minute video then the first
comment would show up three minutes
after the videos republished as opposed
to write when the videos published yeah
your red muslin okay send me your
thoughts about that interesting question